Welcome to lesson two.
Now, at this point you should
have a list of ideas and
hopefully you have a preference for
one that you might want to build.
If you don't, that's all right.
Keep thinking about it,
because we're almost at the point
the point where you've got to choose.
In this lesson, you'll develop a feature
list for each of your app ideas and
then you'll finally choose one.
Once you do, you'll build a paper
prototype, you'll start developing it in
Xcode, you'll find some bugs,
you'll squash those bugs,
then you'll probably find some more
bugs, and then you'll fix those.
But then that'll probably create some
more bugs and then you'll probably just
want to throw your computer out
the window, because screw it.
But we'll have some tips and
tricks to help get you through that,
when you get to that point.
I'll also still be prompting you
to reflect on your experience and
I hope you keep doing so.
Particularly in the forums, because
both you and your fellow classmates
will probably need a bit of
encouragement in this development stage.
Let's get started